foreign
[Music]
I am very worried about her yeah
what is going on this is John with the
Dr John deloney show show about you
and the mess you found yourself in
or the the ashes you're trying to climb
out of this is a show about real people
going through hard stuff and trying to
figure out the scariest question we can
ask ourselves what do I do now
I'm John deloney and I've been walking
alongside people for for 20 years or
more
um helping people figure out what the
next right move is we're talking about
mental health and emotional health on
this show we're talking about our
marriages we're talking about dating
we're talking about kids talking about
all of it whatever we're going through
um my promise is I'll sit with you and
we will work through it and figure it
out if you want to be on this show give
me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask and before we get to our first call
um we are recording this the day after
Father's Day so I hope it was great and
wonderful for you all as I asked some
people when I got to work this morning
it was not great for some of y'all so
I hope this week is Father's day week
for some of y'all if you have to have to
play makeup
um and don't forget if you're gonna buy
supplements buy from the best go to
thorn.com the letter U thorn.com you
slash deloni for a massive massive
discount all right let's go to Lauren in
Phoenix Arizona what's up Lauren
how we doing
good how
good I mean I don't know that I can be
doing better like how's Phoenix
oh it's actually not as bad of a summer
as a lot of them so can't complain very
cool my family back in Texas yesterday
was 111 and I thought oh man that is
that is early to be that hot so I I wish
you all the best this summer
thank you so what's up how can I help
well my big question is my husband
what I can do to take better care of
myself oh man that's hard how long have
you been married
we are going on 11 years now
how long has he been um struggling
um since he was a teenager
so just talk go ahead he was diagnosed
when
Middle School age
um
it was something when we were dating
that he told me about but kind of said
you know it wasn't a big deal and it was
mentioned once and then
um after we were married I found out
that it's a very big deal
not that it would have been a deal
breaker but it was
um something I did not know how to
handle
so paint us a picture of what life is
like loving somebody and building a life
with somebody who
um
has been wrestling with clinical
depression for most of their life
well I honestly didn't understand what
Depression was I grew up in a family
that I didn't talk about mental health a
lot and
um
it kind of
I took on a lot of blame for myself like
why why is this so hard it's because I'm
not doing a good enough job and in our
10 years our first 10 years of marriage
we had already moved 10 times
we are in our 11th Place in the longest
we've ever stayed anywhere and we've
been here two years now
but it's always like
feeling like if you make a change it'll
be better
um
we tried living by my family we tried
living by his family we tried
living in a better warmer environment
we've tried all kinds of different
things and I just kind of like have this
miraculous hope that things are just
going to get easier for us
and of course that doesn't always happen
do you do you recognize now after 10
moves in 10 years that's not true
yeah yeah
there's um You probably heard me say
this on the show before but the worst
part about moving is that you go with
you
yeah the worst part about going around
his family and your family and the new
job than a new place and then another
new job and then let's start our own
business and all those cool things that
just make life an adventure
is that you go with you
yeah
and so I I will high five you and love
you and be here on the phone if you want
to move again and you think something's
going to be different out there
um I'm also
fully ready to dive in if you say I'm
I'm kind of done if you say I'm kind of
done
running from this
I am
you sound tired are you tired
I'm very tired yeah what happened that
precipitated this call
was there a blow up or a scare or a
are you starting
he got really sick with his stomach and
we've been in and out of the ER with it
and they kind of told us it's probably
anxiety related right
um and so I've been worried about his
health a lot and he hasn't been doing
well um
I love my husband and the reason I'm
still here is because he's always trying
to do better trying to find the next
thing that helps he's been through
acupuncture he's been through all kinds
of things
the one thing I haven't gotten him to
try is counseling that's the hardest one
for him
he went through a lot of it as a child
and
doesn't feel like it helps him so he's
not willing to try as an adult
so
oh man
so I won't get into his
um clinical depression if he wants to
call the show I'd be happy to walk down
that rabbit hole with him
um and I'd be happy to lovingly and
as I've done over the course of my
career I I've sit with him and I'll
challenge him appropriately and love him
appropriately that's cool the person
who's on the phone with me today is you
and it's a hurting wife who's tired of
watching her husband
drown who's frustrated when you're
throwing a raft and he won't grab it but
then he yells I've got a new backstroke
that I'm going to try and you jump in
the backstroke with him and you find
yourself further away from Shore and
none of this stuff's working so yeah the
only person on the phone is you and so
I'm gonna tell you a couple of hard
truths and give you some some maybe some
things to try okay
okay here's hard truth number one
you cannot cure or heal your husband's
depression with a period at the end of
that sentence
yeah you've been trying for more than a
decade and you have to stop
you've got you've got to stop
okay
that's exhausting it is and in a really
weird way it creates what I call this
inverted shame cycle
where you try to help him he knows
you're trying to help him he feels
shameful that he has to get kind of help
this kind of help from his wife which
then in somebody struggling with
clinical depression doesn't serve as a
as jet fuel it serves as you know a pile
of of soil it just buries you and that
makes you want to work harder to try to
help and you start saying yes to crazy
ideas and weird things and you're like
I'll try that I'll try that and then he
feels ashamed that you tried that you
see what I'm saying and it just creates
this inverted Loop and somebody at some
point has to break that cycle
and yeah you're the one without clinical
depression so I want to point to you is
that is that a responsibility you would
own
yeah okay here's the greatest gift you
can give your yourself
and as a result of taking care of you
your husband and your marriage okay and
that's for you to strongly and firmly
begin to create really firm boundaries
because your husband has nothing to
Anchor into right now
not that you can be his anchor forever
but he needs somebody in his life to say
I'm not moving anymore I need a home
a friend of mine when I was spinning out
and I was out of control my wife called
him one of my close buddies and he came
home and I was talking about house I'm
gonna sell this house and move to this
house and we're gonna move to this house
and by this time mind you my son had
moved more times in his childhood than I
had in my entire 35 years of life
and my buddy said dude
your wife needs a home
and that sentence was
um
like a like a it was like a knife in my
chest and so
your your husband doesn't have a friend
like that so that's going to be you
saying this is where we live and I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna consider moving for
three to five years I need to make a
home here
I need to make friends I need to have
people over to our house
here are the things I am going to do
because here's what I need I need to
exercise I need to have friends I need
to have a local church I need to have a
um a movie theater that I go to whatever
the things are in your life
um you have to be bold and willing to
say here's what I need and here is where
I am dropping anchor for a season
and because he has not experienced that
that will feel threatening that will
feel disruptive and that might send him
feeling lower
that is not your fault
yeah that's not your fault that will be
his Adventure his journey to heal in
that capacity but this is where we live
or this is my job
so that's number one number two you're
gonna have to feel guilt over resentment
and I say this all the time when it
comes to like in-laws and stuff but
you're gonna have to start saying out
loud here's what I need and here's what
I want
and he might not be able to provide that
for you because he's sick got it you are
gonna go get it
you are gonna go see a counselor
you are gonna go see a marriage
counselor even if he won't go with you
you are going to make sure you go to a
dentist and a health club and you're
going to make sure that you are doing
the things that keep you well in whole
and you haven't done that for a decade
have you
no it's it's hard why is it hard
I moved away
though I know it's lonely
and he is my best friend and he just
doesn't
foreign
are you willing to give him a picture of
what wealth and strength and tiny little
steps towards being whole look like
yeah because I think you've spent a lot
of time sitting with him in the sewage
and that's what great friends that's
what love looks like
[Applause]
the biggest pictures way to describe it
is like he's on a roller coaster instead
of me just saying steady I just write
the ups and downs and
I feel bad when he feels bad because I
want to make him feel better and
I can't
and the greatest gift you can give him
is to get off the roller coaster
completely
just get off
yeah and it's not that you're running
from him it's that you're providing a
stable base a stable platform for him to
to Anchor into
yeah I do I don't see a path for him
being well it's not going to include
some sort of
um significant therapeutic intervention
with a counselor
and maybe he's at a point where he needs
to try his ECT or ketamine or some sort
of psychedelic I mean maybe he needs to
bring in the heavy artillery but he's
going to have to do that therapeutically
with a with a therapist who knows what
they're doing
yeah and there's just no path forward
yeah and I want you to hear me
seeing somebody who's suffered from
major depressive disorder or clinical
depression on the other side of some of
those
um after years of they call it
um like
I don't use those technical terms it's
depression becomes so so challenging and
to see people on the other side of this
that are looks like a light came on so I
want you to hear me say there is hope
thank you there is what I would call
radical hope friends of mine who just
quit drinking after a decade and after
some of these treatments and they're a
joy and they had kids and they're they
laugh a lot and they make fun of them
old selves like their old selves in in
unimaginable ways
the hard part is
you can't get him there he's gonna have
to choose that path
what you can give him though is a
real-time picture of what it looks like
and he's you're gonna break that cycle I
was talking about and everything in his
body will try to reconstruct that cycle
all right he might get extra low he
might get extra mean he might get extra
fulfill in the blank you can't control
any of his responses to that what you
can control is this one sentence I'm
worth being well
yeah whatever that looks like is that
fair
yep
I'm really proud of you
I'm proud of you for loving this guy for
more than a decade in the way you have
and I'm proud of you for saying this is
as far as I can go and I don't know what
to do and I'm proud of you for calling
it's hard
I'm gonna be proud of you every step of
the way you take um and by the way
healing from depression is I mean it's
it's little wins baby steps little wins
little wins little wins
tiny little steps that suddenly become
big changes over time it's like compound
interest and it's the weight of these
massive changes that keeps people locked
up and it's that's not how you heal from
major depression major depression it's
teeny tiny things and it's brain
chemistry in its therapy and it is some
of these new therapies that have come
out that are just looking to be magic
and it's a wife that says I'm getting
off the roller coaster and I'm gonna be
well I'm gonna create a platform or a
foundation for you to Anchor into if you
want to and if you're willing to
hang on the line here I'm going to send
you a copy of when your past change your
future I want you to read that book and
I here's my promise I'll be with you
every step of the way sweetheart I'm
proud of you I'm proud of you I'm proud
of you
um
start taking care of Lauren
they're taking care of Lauren because
that's the one person
you can help right now we'll be right
back
[Music]
the show is sponsored by better help
folks take a minute to think about how
much time you spend on yourself it's
easy to get caught up in what people
need from you and want from you and
never think about what you need and then
you end up too stretched out burned out
all of the madness of our current world
resting on your shoulders
look sometimes I put my head down to
work and then realize I haven't had a
meaningful conversation with my wife and
kids all day I get focused on what I'm
doing and I'm running and running and
running
and I don't know how to come back
and therapy is a great way to learn new
skills that make you the best version of
yourself they help you set boundaries
and still have energy left to help
others without leaving yourself behind
so if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
totally online to fit into your schedule
you just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with the licensed
therapist and you can switch therapists
at any time for no additional charge so
find more balance find Wellness with
better help visit betterhelp.com deloney
today to get 10 off your first month
that's a better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go out to
Asheboro North Carolina one of those
beautiful places in the country what's
up Bradley
hey Dr John how you doing today great
man how are you I'm doing good what's up
uh well so my question is my I have five
kids
and they are at my mom's for the summer
just hanging out doing summer fun things
with them
and uh basically one wife and I we are
considering selling our current home and
buying a new home while they're gone
could it be easier to move with no kids
in the way of moving but is it weird to
like then go pick up the kids and just
come back and be like hey here's our new
house like should we have a conversation
with the kids like through FaceTime or I
mean they're eight and under so most of
them
in my mind like won't even really be you
know they're easily adjustable but then
again at the same time like I could see
that being a big deal for kids you have
five kids eight and under
yeah yeah they're all about 18 months
apart
I bet your house is so so incredibly
still right now is it amazing it is it's
awkwardly still like I I'm used to a
quiet band something is getting
destroyed and now it's just peace and
it's weird are they at your parents
house
yeah yeah my mom
is your mom and dad just like snorting
Xanax off the bathroom counter how are
they doing this
I don't know they're they they're uh
they're Troopers for sure I could just
see your mom being like well your dad
started smoking again and no that hey
that's that's great
um how far away is your parents house
how far away are they from you guys uh
12 hours oh very Mississippi oh wait man
you have a how old's your youngest
uh two that two-year-old is not going to
see y'all for the whole summer
uh well so we we plan a Midway visit to
basically to kind of uh you know hang
out for a few days okay and uh so and I
yeah it's we're testing that this is the
first summer we're we're trying it okay
uh it wouldn't surprise me if that
two-year-old or that I guess there's a
four-year-old if a two and a
four-year-old end up needing to come
home halfway through maybe right um that
wouldn't surprise me that's that's a lot
a lot of separation from Mom and Dad for
a two and four year old
it is just developmentally that's a lot
but uh maybe with their brothers and
sisters eight six and five I mean even
five that's that's a long time but all
I'd say that's not even why you called
so if I find myself in your situation so
you're thinking about selling the house
y'all live in it'd be so much it's
easier to do everything just it's just
going to the bathroom is so so much
easier
um having breakfast is so much easier
but you're thinking about selling your
house and moving to a whole new place
nothing especially you know I'm in the
housing market it's crazy but uh
my wife was looking at home values and
realized that like basically for the
price for the value of ours we could
there's like new developments in new
neighborhoods growing up that have much
more you know playgrounds and things
like that is that we could uh
potentially give
you know being in a better situation
more rooms for the same price so I could
you know uh as we currently are in where
we're in like a 1960s home where at any
point you know something could really go
wrong uh we could end up being in a
newer one with the same money basically
yeah I mean and and new things are going
to go wrong in I mean in new houses too
so what I what I want you to do is to if
y'all decide to move great I don't want
you to create a bunch of problems where
you live now
I'd much rather you see some opportunity
somewhere else
yeah right
um because your house
I'm I'm convinced that the house you're
in right now you could raise all all
five of these kids and you and your wife
and it would be tight and be maniacal
and you'd be loud and all those things
but y'all could do it you're seeing some
new developments that have some cool
amenities that you guys want as your
family that might make your life more
fun or a little bit easier or whatever
no
that's all well and good so if you were
to sell your house and let's pretend it
sold in 30 days and you were gonna move
and let's pretend in August August 1st
is your move date and you're out of here
and
um your two-year-old and your
four-year-old have come back home
um
here's what I would do in that situation
I would have a place picked out that I'm
I put an offer in this is going to be
our home I would not say hey we're
thinking about moving this or that or
that or this or anything like that
I would say we found a place and here's
why those kids that young the ambiguity
the you instantly pull the tether out it
doesn't make sense whereas you and your
wife are like hey we should look at some
houses that can become fun and that can
become an adventure for a kid it can be
unsettling
but okay you guys you guys find a place
here's where we're gonna go
then you take pictures of where their
bedrooms will be and what we're going to
move um it's a it's it's Piaget and it's
old we're going to move into very
concrete this is going to be your room
what color would you like it to be red
or orange orange or pink
that way they get the concreteness we
are moving to a new house hey look
here's a picture of the pool here's a
picture of the playground here are some
things that are going to be very real in
our lives and
you get some ownership in this move
however small it might be
and by giving them some ownership they
are have a vested interest they move I I
Can't Describe other than they move into
that choice and that decision and when
they walk in that sense of this is all
new and this is all kind of freaky is
also I picked that color that's mine
and this is my room or this is our like
if you're sharing rooms this is our room
and we picked this and maybe you asked
doing a baseball poster or a Hello Kitty
post I don't know what your kids are
into but find one or two little little
variables that they get a choice in all
the way down to your
maybe even your four-year-old but for
sure your your your eight-year-old I
guess you have a six you have a seven or
something like that five year old
something like that yeah yeah yeah eight
six
you're six and your five-year-old I
would sit them down separately than the
other two
and say we're gonna have a big kid
conversation we found an amazing new
house that's gonna give more space
that's going to be by a new park in a
pool and they're gonna go wow and then
one or two of those kids if not all of
them will go but I like our old house
and what about my room and that's when
you can say check this out and you can
have an iPad for them or even put on a
big screen TV and say this is going to
be your room and you get to pick between
baseball or football or whatever and
like whatever and whatever and you get
to pick this color which one do you want
and just go through it that way and that
way when they show up it's more of a
sense of ownership and not a sense of
they pulled the wool out from under me
the worst thing you can do was just
drive home and pick them up
new house and then they will never feel
settled for the rest of their life
that's not true they would be fine but
um I definitely wouldn't do that but I
would I would bring them into it when
you have some some security this is
where we're moving this is the house and
when they can have tiny little bits of
ownership
um I think that's that's awesome
okay yeah thanks I appreciate it you
know the older ones were my main concern
and then uh
yeah who knows we might get to getting
everything past ready and then decide
hey we still really like this house but
I had a um I had a a professor a
counseling Professor her name's Aretha
marbley she's just
um really important person in my life
she gave me some advice when my wife got
pregnant with Josephine
um six years after we had Hank and she
said you can avoid all of the problems
that having at the first kid experiences
with your second kid if you'll just do
one thing and I rolled my eyes I was
like whatever everybody's giving me all
this stupid parenting advice and she
said just from this point forward start
referring to your wife's pregnancy as
his baby
just his baby
and what I didn't understand
developmentally at the time
um was he was very very young but he was
so desperate kids are so desperate for
any shred of ownership
and his parents we can't give them a lot
of ownership and we're there's some kind
of weird cultural Zeitgeist where it's
like we they do we tell us and we tell
them that's terrible parenting but if we
teach them little bits of hey here's
what ownership looks like and feels like
and you get to pick this
and if one of them throws a temper
tantrum I don't want to move I hate this
that's fine you just took like there you
move their house on them that's cool
when you're ready to come back and have
this conversation we'll be happy to I'm
sorry that you're choosing to throw a
temper tantrum over a really neat thing
but I do understand that this is scary
for you so when you're ready to choose
what room color you want come on back we
can't wait for you to be here and I'm
gonna let them go have their little fit
and go do the little thing I I'm not
going to get affected by that I'm gonna
do what's best for my family right
um but man you give them a little bit of
ownership whether it comes to having a
brother sister you give them a little
ownership into
um their appearance and how the room
looks or little bits of ownership uh man
goes to such a long long way with with
um childhood development so well done
man
I don't know how you all pulled the scam
of the century sending all five of those
kids away but well done well done and uh
best of luck to you man if you do get a
new house send us a picture and we'll
post it up here man can't wait we'll be
right back
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling hallow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com deloney today to get three
months of hollow for free
hallow.com deloney
all right we're back let's go out to
Dear Marie and what Madison Wisconsin
what's up Marie
it's a little surreal to be talking to
you it's very serial to be talking to
you I promise what's up uh I am calling
and I'll just phrase my question first
but I am calling um because of my sister
I would like to know how I can still
possibly help her out but protect my
family and her sanity as she is a child
in an adult body and is making choices
day to day that are devoid from reality
and I can definitely give you kind of
the back story yeah is she a child in
adult body cognitively like she's got um
she's got cognitive impairment or she's
just an adult being a
pretty much the same
okay okay yeah tell me more I want to
hear this story
so I am an adult skeptical child I left
home over 12 years ago and went no
contact seven years ago with very few
exceptions literally my exception is
funerals and my grandma's 90th party
um
I am not 32. okay all right so I helped
my sister who is a doormat or Invisible
Child
um get out about six years ago now and
she only decided to leave quote unquote
after a very uh traumatic event that her
parents have put her through but she
still maintains contact what's that
event
what's that what's the event
the event that I'm calling about today
no what's the traumatic event she
escaped from yeah the traumatic event
that uh she uh had was it's really messy
but
um so there is a a man that showed up
um in our life and
um my parents I have I'm
we're part of a family of eight kids so
I'm able to see the each um she was the
second and then there's a third one and
the third one is definitely narcissistic
my mother is a narcissist too in the
family if it um helps but the traumatic
event was this man showed up and my
parents were kind of trying to for he
wanted to be with Kayla Kayla said he
was like quote unquote dating her
secretly and they were forcing him onto
our third sister Teresa and he told her
at some point that he's like I want to
be with you I'm going to date you I'm
going to tell your parents today and
then what ended up happening was he got
there my dad's like you need to choose
you need to choose anything like pretty
much screaming yelling in his face this
is what my sister has informed me about
and she uh
um she said that she's like all right I
choose District three and Kayla was just
completely devastated after that and
then he just jumped in his car and
laughed and that was it and it's like an
old Bible story yeah
how old is your sister
I oh gosh this is six plus years ago so
it's like 20 24 25 when this happened
how old was Sister number three
months younger than that so there's 18
months between the first four so they
were 23 and 24 or 25 living at home
yep and your dad was trying to arrange
marriage then with this this mystery man
the other messy part by the way is he
was also engaged to someone else and I
found this
all right this this is like even Jerry
Springer would be like all right that's
that's that's enough of this all right
so so yeah you want to help your sister
so as your sister is she still live at
home is she moved out or what no she's
moved on this is actually why I called
so she just informed me a few weeks ago
that she's seven months pregnant closer
to eight now okay and my husband and I
just had our first child here back we've
been married six years so we just had
our first child in January and she
claims that she didn't tell me because
we were expecting our child and she
didn't want to focus to be on that and
she knew how I'd react it was more
reacting to the father because as
um I know you know is there's a lot of
repeat with relationships we have to
relive the trauma almost and my sister
has been going to therapy for five years
but she continues with the relationships
where people are emotionally mentally
and financially abusing her all things
in her family did and the father of her
child he is one of those toxic abusive
types and at the time I wrote him we
were aware of four times that he's
cheated
um this is during the first phase of
them dating and second phase started up
again last year and just this week I
learned that she had put a tracker on
his car last year and found out that he
was cheating again so now there's five
total times and
um it was my aunt that told me this not
my sister
um my sister also submitted that he's
financially abused her in the past five
weeks ago she moved in with him okay so
how can I help you what do you want to
do
I want to help her but she went and she
kind of reached out to me you can't I
know I I know but she had reached out to
me that she wanted out because she
called me saying that it was really
messy and how about it
I am very worried about her yeah it's
pretty much of taking care of all my
siblings my whole life I was the not
only a scapegoat but I was the parent
yeah
so and here's what needs to happen
really quick okay and this is just you
and then we can get to the other things
the other people okay
there's part of this frantic I can hear
it in the call there's part of this
frantic
need to be the person who's out like
you're the you're the
the scanner system for everybody in the
family for the brothers and sisters for
the who's dating who and your body is
running on drama it's running on
cortisol and adrenaline
that's how that's how you operate and
you've been running that way since you
were a little bitty girl because you
grew up in chaos with really crappy
parents Fair yeah it's fair but I
honestly Dr John I run from Channel
which is why I call because I'm ready to
run again away from this because I don't
want this in my family okay or my family
being my husband my child sure
absolutely so here's the only way it
works to balance I really really love my
family members and I want to take care
of them
and they are
um making really poor decisions and I'm
not gonna allow that poison into my home
because this cycle stops with me
yeah right so here's here's what that
means I'm never the moment somebody
starts to tell me about one of my
sister's boyfriends I'm I'm I end that
conversation done I don't want to hear
it don't care I don't want to hear it
okay the moment somebody starts talking
about would you hear your sister did she
no don't want to hear it I I I I I'm not
going to engage in that sort of gossipy
conversation I'm clearing my life for
that mess
I will talk to my sister
on a regular basis
of some sort
and if my sister wants my help here's
what that's going to look like
you will get rid of your cell phone you
will never contact this guy again you'll
go to court and get full custody you
like whatever you need to do because
you're not bringing that's Insanity into
my house
and I want you in my house here's the
thing she's gonna have to make grown-up
choices yeah
and you're gonna have to make grown-up
choices too but we have to we have to
create a place of of
of Steel and concrete so that anybody
who needs help can anchor into it and
right now you care about them so much
you're willing to dive back into that
mess that you've spent so long healing
from
to an extent I'm not willing to dive
into it which is why I'm calling because
okay that's fair she starts
I know they're going someplace I will
not go good because I don't
invited them because my mother being who
she is but
um and hey I I would stop with all
diagnostic language
yeah sorry like no I'm just saying this
like it'll it'll give you peace
well I I mean I'm trained in that and I
don't refer to my friends as like that
guy's got depression and that guy's got
anxiety yeah I don't even do that and I
know all the lingo I just will simply
say yeah that person makes me feel
uncomfortable or that person brings too
much chaos I'm just gonna I'm gonna bow
out yeah okay I don't know if your mom
has narcissistic personality disorder if
she's just mean if she has a lot of
trauma in her childhood here's the deal
it doesn't matter
she treated you like crap and she stole
from you and was abusive and your dad's
track trafficking his adult daughters in
a weird way like just the whole thing's
just a mess and so yeah I'm out like I
I'll leave your Diagnostics to the
psychiatrist I'm out
um I'm gonna go create a great life and
if you can move across the country
good
I put my foot down I would not move back
to the state that everyone was in yeah I
mean so you're like um so you're proving
me wrong you are really working hard to
heal and that's awesome you
this is the one sister that I have
contact with because like I said I
helped her out but she's these choices
she's making now she has a baby girl
that she's about to have is part of me
again this is where my my go-to for
response has always been flight that's
why I'm an workaholic and I know it but
it's just is this the time where I have
to I guess why run again and just walk
and like walk away but always let her
know the door is open when she is ready
to actually make those adult decisions I
think you're done running
okay but I think that you now have gone
out to the front of your property and
built a pretty firm boundary
okay and so I don't want you to look at
saying no as some sort of trauma
response it's this is this is you
speaking out of a position of strength
and health
this is what healing looks like
unfortunately we think that when we heal
it's gonna be like all right
everything's gonna be awesome
it's not because the world around us
hasn't yet
in fact sometimes getting well healing
and living in a peaceful situation
um can be unnerving one because our
nervous system Only Knows chaos and when
it has no chaos it will either spin it
up and create it or it will try to
achieve something to make us feel good
we got to get a drilling somewhere right
or um it will feel like depression and
we'll end up just sitting there drinking
or netflixing our lives away and so
I get that impulse but this sounds like
you're operating not from
a trauma response not from running but
it sounds like you were
like you've drawn a hard line
and you can go out to the gates and you
can hand her a piece of paper that says
here's the here's what it will take for
you to come to my home
okay and that can be whatever you and
your husband decide it's going to be
and she needs to know if she comes to
your house or if she becomes a part of
your life here is what will get her sent
away
all right if you bring an abusive man
into this home if you're in contact with
somebody that's abusive you're allowed
to do that but you cannot live here
if you swear if you smoke in the house I
don't care I don't care what it is yeah
um you can you can make any rules you
want because it's your place yeah
and what you what you can give somebody
over time here's my guess my guess is
she's gonna get really mad at you like
you're leaving me like you you're you're
just bailing on me or you're all high
and mighty or you escaped and it's how
lucky it is to be you and all that
nonsense
and you're going to choose guilt over
resentment every single time
because you don't ever want to hate your
sister right
no I I don't hate my sister I know but
but if she moves into your house with
this new little baby and that boy comes
around and then that boy you walk in one
day and that man is alone with your kid
you know you will hate your sister we're
not going there yeah we're going to
choose guilt we're going to put strong
boundaries up and if sister doesn't
doesn't
um
doesn't live into the boundaries you
make for your life and for your family
then she's opting out and I'm gonna feel
guilty about that because I want to help
her but she's choosing not to not not to
take help right now
yeah right you're getting back in that
chaos isn't going to help
is there any way that you know of where
you can because she she's almost
creating a a delusional world right now
like I said she was open to moving talk
to him and just being who he is
um it's just she's no
the hair is on our end no the only one
that I know of is constant touches with
reality and that is you deciding I'm
going to write her a letter every week
it just tells her I love her and here's
a great thing that happened and here's
the weather I'm talking about some very
detailed reality things
um or I'm gonna call you once a week and
we're gonna talk for 30 minutes and then
at 30 minutes your watch is going to
beep or your phone's gonna beep and
you're literally gonna say all right I
gotta run
have a great even if it's in the middle
of a of a conversation you're going to
what you're doing is you're you are
modeling in real time what boundaries
look like what peace looks like hey me
and my husband are going on a date
tonight so we got a big romantic one
planned we got a babysitter coming over
so you all have a great night I'm going
on my date oh it must be nice oh my gosh
I wish I yep yeah
it's really incredible and I hope you'll
join me someday have a great one and I'm
hanging up right I'm getting out
um but no there's no way
that you can get involved and make her
choose not this guy who's a gas lighter
and whatever and a whatever and whatever
and a partridge and a pear tree you
can't do anything about that you can
provide an alternative
um an alternative place of peace and
safety for her but she's gonna have to
opt in
and I hate that for both of you I
especially hate it for that little bitty
baby girl that's on the way
because that little baby girl didn't
didn't ask for any of this nonsense
but dude I'm proud of you Marie for
getting out proud of you for creating
strong boundaries and saying not for me
and my family not anymore
and I know that that felt like once we
got established everything was going to
be just ah
and it's not sometimes when we heal our
eyes are open to just how chaotic and
madhouse the rest of the world actually
is
create a peaceful home and then create
the boundaries by which people can enter
it
it's guilt over resentment every time
we'll be right back
[Music]
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right we are back
um
got an email here from Victoria Locke
pretty amazing
Victoria says
I'm sitting next to my mom who's on
hospice after a two-year battle with
brain cancer
last year my best friend from college
told me the classic if there's anything
you need you let me know and she added
if your mom wants to backpack the Grand
Canyon again I will help carry gear for
her
I dismissed this offer at first thinking
it was crazy however I later decided
that it was worth a shot I bought the
permit and started planning my friend
brought two friends two of her friends
to help my sister Brittany came to
to make a long story short we pulled off
the trip and I will never regret doing
it
I'm just gonna pause right there
what a great friend
like metaphorically and in in reality
I'll carry your gear
when you can't I'll be there
to make a long story short short we
pulled off the trip and I'll never
regret doing it we laughed together had
questions for humans conversations yeah
yes
saw the Stars drank wine chased sunsets
ran away from rain and had a generally
good time
mom gave me a beautiful example of what
it looks like to live fully and
courageously no matter what life hands
me
and she got an example
deep in her soul
of what raising an extraordinary
daughter looks like
because she raised a daughter who would
grow up to be an amazing woman who had
great friends and who knew what care and
compassion looked like and knew what
planning looked like and knew what
um hard scary things were going to do
them anyway because we only got one more
shot looks like
your mom gave you a gift but Victoria
you gave her I can't I can't imagine a
greater gift from my kids
because of my mom I will choose to treat
this one life like the precious gift it
is
Victoria that's incredible
thank you for sharing this thank you for
taking questions for humans with you
down to the bottom of the Grand Canyon
those cards have ended up in places I
never in a million years would have
imagined but the thought
of a mom
dying from brain cancer
and her daughter
and her daughter's friends
sitting in the bottom of the Grand
Canyon
laughing telling stories drinking a
little bit too much doing questions for
humans looking at the stars
man that can get me choked up thank you
for allowing me to have uh teeny tiny
little
um
place in this amazing Story You're a
good daughter raised by an extraordinary
mom she's lucky to have you as you were
lucky to have her
thank you all so much for listening to
the show that's it for today stay in
school don't do drugs have fun and make
good choices we'll see you soon love
y'all